when I say game company you think of
Nintendo Sony Microsoft those who shall
not be named unless you have a really
good memory or really love chess you
don't think of Apple and for a pretty
good reason
you can drop $13,000 on a brand-new iMac
Pro and only have a decent gaming
machine and because it's not upgradable
not for very long but hey it is Space
Gray Macs can play games the same way a
smart car can drive cross-country sure
it's possible but kinda by accident
Apple may have far more resources than
Microsoft or Sony but to make a gaming
platform they'd really have to want one
and right now they just don't at least
that's how it looks for many people
computers are just Facebook or YouTube
or email machines for them a phone or
tablet is increasingly good enough the
trend is portability over performance
which isn't so good for the PC market
but there's one big exception PC gaming
it has all the characteristics of a tiny
niche market but it isn't it's actually
growing many gamers buy parts to build
their own computers and regularly
upgrade them to keep up with new games
this saves a lot of money and for
companies
margins are pretty low so as much as
Johnny hive would love to fix this and
this seriously these look ridiculous it
just doesn't fit Apple strategy vague
upgradable machines sold for low margins
are pretty much their nightmare Apple
will pass on billion dollar industries
without blinking an eye if they don't
have something significant to add so a
chart like this one looks terrible for
Apple Android phones dominate the globe
but they don't really care because of
this they're happy selling fewer phones
because it fits their strategy they're
just so good at making profit but that's
actually precisely why they already are
in the business of gaming they just have
a very different approach for you gaming
may look like this or this but the truth
is for even more people it looks like
this mobile gaming is a forty six
billion dollar market more profitable
than PC games console games even global
box office sales on any given day candy
crush alone makes
two million dollars fortnight is
expected to make half a billion dollars
this year not bad at all and Apple takes
a 30% cut of all app store revenue
obviously they aren't only or mostly a
game company but at this point it's hard
to deny they aren't a game company you
might be thinking Apple just stumbled
into this there are no more a game
company than your internet service
provider is a YouTube company but the
app store isn't just another App Store
it's really the game store the game
store the App Store is 25% games far
more than any other category
last year they redesign the entire store
to emphasize them and game developers
love the store just as much as the store
loves them good games are expensive to
make even what seems like a simple game
may require a team of programmers
another for art and music and writing
and marketing like movies it's a huge
upfront investment with a ton of risk
but the promise of digital goods is that
once they're made they're made no
manufacturing or transportation or
stocking costs one game one click of a
button now millions of people can
download it but because google says
here's some software now go make phones
and manufacturers are desperate to stand
out Android is a nightmare for game
developers there are two inch Android
phones probably 2 meter Android phones
and everything in between do you want a
phone that can tell you how fat you are
how about one engraved with Colonel
Sanders face if you can think of it
Android has it and they're all sprinkled
between a million different versions of
Android when you're making a game this
means accommodating tens of thousands of
different phones not so fun
compare that to iOS and you can see its
appeal 76 percent run the latest iOS
version on Android it's only 5 this is
why Apple is so pesky about updating
your phone it adds a ton of value to
their company and sorry a Microsoft
Store it might be really easy to develop
for you but nobody has a Windows Phone
Apple also has the advantage of
designing its own processors which means
developers can make better crispy or
games on iPhone they're kind of
embarrassingly faster than some of
Apple's own laptops but the biggest
reason companies choose the App Store is
simple iOS users pay twice as much
apps games like Super Mario run and
fortnight came to iOS first because
that's where the money is and Apple is
very aware they've partnered with
Nintendo Epic Games EA that game company
even scarf guy the iPhone iPad and still
a product in our lineup ipod touch or
maybe the most popular gaming devices
but there's still a lot more Apple could
do in 2015 Apple announced a new
generation Apple TV not just an
expensive way to watch Netflix more a
computer it still plays Netflix and Hulu
and eventually Amazon but it's a
general-purpose entertainment device it
has its own app store with games even
third-party game controllers it's no
Xbox or Wii but it has the potential to
become the console for casual gamers but
they made one major mistake games had to
be compatible with a built in remote but
the remote well it sucks for gaming and
because of that rule games could only be
as good as the remote Apple has now
reversed that decision but now they're
having a chicken or egg problem for many
people there aren't enough good games to
buy an Apple TV but developers won't
make games until there are more people
to buy them so which comes first and a
lot of games now require a controller
but nobody has one so here's an idea
what if instead of selling two sizes of
the Apple TV they sold two versions for
gamers a more expensive higher
performance higher storage model that
comes with a controller and a slightly
cheaper lower performance lower storage
version for everyone else more people
would have controllers which would bring
more and better games which brings even
more people and so on it might still be
tough getting developers to make games
for the Apple TV but there's a good
reason to think Apple is working on that
there's a rumor they'll allow developers
to make one app for several platforms so
instead of having to make one version of
their app for Mac and one for iOS or
more likely just doing the latter they
could kill two birds with one stone if
this also worked for Apple TV it could
bring a ton of
new games to the platform Apple is in a
great position to create a very
profitable new gaming platform
especially with how ruthless game
companies can be the new youtube channel
cheddar has a video about this very
topic how games use micro transactions
and paedo and purchases to maximize
profits it also makes an interesting
counter-argument and I hadn't really
thought about that one benefit of these
free-to-play games is that they're
accessible to everyone even if you don't
have disposable income but as they
mention it's reached crazy levels with
games like battlefront - cheddar has
very generously sponsored this video
because if you like my videos you might
also like there's there's a link in the
description to watch their video on
pay2win gaming or you can check out some
of their other videos like cheddar
explains the dot-com bubble a topic I've
always heard about but having been born
right in the MU of it didn't know much
about or cheddar explains the future of
cable TV how younger generations are
forever changing the industry all of
those will be in the description and
thanks again to cheder for supporting
the channel
[Music]